usually it's not too tough to guess how
our film is going to turn out especially
in the days of multiple trailers
trailers for different regions teasers
for those trailers and even sometimes
teasers for the teasers other times it's
not quite as easy as these films of
surprising Rotten Tomatoes scores proved
mortal engines should have been a
surefire hit it's got Peter Jackson as a
co-producer and co-writer and it's based
on a successful why a franchise heck
it's about giant mobile cities that eat
each other to survive seems like a
license to print money but unfortunately
that still wasn't enough to succeed with
fans and critics earning a twenty six
percent on Rotten Tomatoes is rough by
almost any standard but there's
something odd about watching a film that
seems tailor-made to launch a massive
franchise sputter out before it even
left the starting line the mortal
engines didn't just bomb with critics
according to IMDB the film is an
estimated budget of one hundred million
dollars and as of late January 2019 it
had just barely cleared the 80 million
dollar mark in worldwide gross it's
doubtful we'll see a follow up no matter
how ready-made for success mortal
engines seems on paper the Transformers
franchise isn't exactly known as a
critical darling even if it does seem to
have the uncanny ability to print money
while the original live-action entry for
the Robots in Disguise under
surprisingly respectable 57 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes subsequent entries
haven't fared as well few would
reasonably expect the first Transformers
spin-off to warrant the theatres with a
93% on Rotten Tomatoes to round out 2018
luckily bumblebee has got some star
power in his tank and a can't-miss
formula as its chassis director Travis
Knight injects a flake with late 80s
flavor thanks to its period setting and
the guardians of the galaxy like
approach to the soundtrack picking
appropriate timely hits to keep the
energy up meanwhile Hailee Steinfeld's
turn as a young Charlie gives the movie
more than enough heart to let audiences
get invested in her friendship with the
anthropomorphic VW Bug
[Music]
the first Mamamia movie was a hit with
fans of the original Broadway musical
and anyone who knows the truth the Abba
rules that didn't necessarily translate
to making it a hit with critics since it
was only able to obtain a 55% of Rotten
Tomatoes but the truly baffling decision
to stage a sequel ended up paying off
both critically and financially a
fantastically titled Mamma Mia here we
go again is certifiably fresh at 81% and
raked in 394 million dollars at the box
office while much of the enjoyment of
the sequel comes from the ridiculous
setups for his musical set pieces the
true shining beacon of here we go again
a share who steals every scene she's in
as a mother of Meryl Streep's character
the broadcast but a Terranea musical
celebration is dripping with Smoltz but
it works
walking the very thin line between
earnest and cheesy makes for some
magical moments in what could have been
a money-grubbing solar sequel Nicolas
Cage doesn't seem like he can say no to
a movie which often leads him to getting
stuck in some absolute clunkers however
his chaotic messy turn in Mandy arrived
in service of the first film in years to
take full advantage of cages peek gonzo
sensibilities Mandy became an instant
cult hit and had critics raving after
its release resulting in a 91 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes
Mandy follows Kate and a mind-bending
gory journey of revenge aimed at Colton
a group of drug addled demon bikers it
doesn't necessarily sound like a movie
that might be sitting at the top of
critics list in 2018 but fans and
critics alike responded to the stylized
violence and shocking imagery of Monday
a perfect storm of Academy Award and
Golden Globe Award nominee Ava Duvernay
directing an adaptation of the
children's classic a wrinkle in time
still couldn't well critics the film is
currently saddled with a 42% on the
service with an even lower fan rating of
28% a wrinkle in time introduces
audiences to the precocious meg Murray
played by newcomer storm Reed as she's
led on a time and space spending journey
in search of her father while some
critics were wowed by the film's CGI
wonders others father the affair
Bogg the film down and made it a little
too cheesy that's one word for it the
film where's its heart and ambitions on
its sleeves and it will be interesting
to see if it persists as a cult favorite
2018 ended up being a banner year for
spider-man related media both venom took
a bit of a beating from critics the film
as a master fervent fanbase and more
than made back its estimated 100 million
dollar budgets spider-man into the
spider verse could have been that
animated also ran to cap off the air but
it ended up blowing the spider-man
franchise wide open and impressing
critics at the same time it's currently
sitting at 97 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
Spider versus stellar animation alone
but set it up to be a game-changer but
the immense heart at the core of the
story propels it into something truly
special even critics exhausted by the
superhero movie bubble had to admit that
into the spider verse was a step above
wherever I go than in charge wind it
smash the green game night could have
come and gone without much fanfare
due to its incredibly generic and bland
marketing campaign which hit a raucous
critic pleasing comedy the movie stars
Rachel McAdams and Jason Bateman as a
competitive couple who have bonded over
their shared love of games Kyle Chandler
playing Batemans brother hosts a game
night framed as an immersive experience
in which one of the guests is kidnapped
the twist the kidnapping is real
that was amazing
Adam Graham of the Detroit News gave
game-like credit for being an adult
movie that never stooped to lowbrow
humor calling it quote a crowd-pleaser
to which all want to be invited all that
positive firsts added up to game night
scoring an 84 percent overall rating on
Rotten Tomatoes Duncan Jones is an
interesting director with a tomato meter
record that was only recently derailed
by his odd stint as a director of the
critically ill fated Warcraft movie
before that he was riding high with the
Loki sci-fi masterpiece moon and his
2011 follow up the Jake Gyllenhaal
thriller source code Warcraft was still
a financial success especially outside
of the United States but fans were eager
for Jones to return to his own stories
characters and worlds his next piece of
work 2018 s Netflix distributed mute was
described as a blade runner-esque
excursion suggesting a strong rebound
not quite while mute looks like a return
to form it ended up being a generic
lifeless mess with not much to say and
not much to show for it except a 20% of
Rotten Tomatoes what happens when a
troubled biopic about an infamous
gangster that's been in production for
years ends up being a dull boring slog
and goodbye bizarre performance from
John Travolta and Nets a resounding zero
percent overall on Rotten Tomatoes
biopic starring famous actors are
usually critical hits this one not so
much
Rolling Stones Peter Travers spoke for
many of his peers when he compared it to
a lifeless version of The Sopranos I
can't watch it again check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]